I like to thank everybody for joining
this lab routes webcast
the title is strategies to improve
laboratory stewardship and I will tell
you our experience over the past many
years as well as to point out an
excellent document that can either get
you started or help you along the way if
you're already started so the who why
what how this document and I I have no
financial benefits from the selling of
this document I did function as the
chair of the group that was brought
together to make this document it's a
clsi document GP 49 developing and
managing a medical laboratory test
utilization management program and I
just think is a wonderful document to
have on in your library who who wrote it
I will say they I was so thrilled to be
able to work with really folks who are
legends in the field and have done this
for much of their life and who should do
this work locally it will really talk to
that within the document it explains the
DeWyze vaccination of the change in work
scape and reimbursement differences from
volume to value based reimbursement many
of these types of things describes why
certain tests need not be performed one
of the things I think is most important
about it is it has great recipes in it
what to do so if you're at a loss for an
idea you can see what some of these
legends have done over the years how was
this created it really is a clinical
laboratory standards Institute process
which is the creation of consensus
documents and so that is exactly what
this is it's consensus of this group and
as engineers examples and ways to report
your successes so on many of this
further the first portion of this talk
comes as
excerpts from this document and first of
all it's talking about how to do it
right and this really probably is
obvious to all of us but we know that
gets done wrong all the time so anything
else must be wrong how you use tests
correctly well the credit creek just has
to be ordered in the correct situation
of course and when that doesn't occur we
have issues specimen needs to be
collected correctly the laboratory needs
to perform the tests in a precise
accurate timely manner and we know that
if there are our analytical errors leads
to repeats if results aren't available
in time Doc's will get impatient and
reorder it leads to repeats and the test
needs to provide clinically useful
information that is interpreted
correctly and acted upon promptly and
appropriately and so this really speaks
to having an effector arm to your
program us doing tests analytically
correct is not enough we have to reach
out before the test and make sure it's
correct and we need to make sure after
the test somebody's acting on it and
this is really important that we
recognize we are part of a larger system
and this is really systems based
practice so your team structure and
function you're gonna have an initial
framework commitment and investment
essential resources organizational
approach and program management and we
will talk about each of these and so our
title is about strategy so in the bog
strategies and tactics are gimmicks that
will have limited impact unless so the
intervention is true we're doing this
for the right reasons and the correct
people are engaged so we really need to
think of a mode why are we doing it and
who's on this team and your team
composition may change depending on your
projects so initial framework this
document brings forth the idea that no
one-size-fits-all you really have to
look at look at how other folks are
doing it
and look at what would work at your
institution all politics are local so
you also need to have organizational and
individual alignment if I want to work
on certain test issues and there's no
organizational support for that it's not
going to go very far so one of the
things you can do is look at the
direction of your organization your
organization's building a new Cancer
Center they probably like some help on
the stewardship of tests and results
from oncological the other thing is in
this and any other meetings you really
you just have to have the nuts and bolts
down of good business practice right you
need to have a meeting schedule
responsibilities and action items keep
minutes etc all the things that we know
work but sometimes we let slip
commitment and investment this really
resides at all levels you're going to
have to have organizational leadership
support on this this really needs to be
more than just moral support you
actually are going to sometimes need to
have a part of a project manager funded
for example but you may need to get
bumped up in the queue to get data out
of the informatics system so the other
thing too is sometimes the interventions
that you do are gonna make people
unhappy so you may want to make sure to
sell this up before you and have
approval and buy-in before you move
these projects into operations you're
gonna really need programmatic
leadership but you have to be aware of
becoming a heroic leader and doing all
of the work yourself they'll be afraid
to delegate people are on your committee
plate because they want to work in this
space so give them some law work to do
team members you're gonna want to have
team members that are committed engaged
active actives they have some work to do
they're reporting back on something put
on laboratory stakeholders you're really
we are not doing this just from the
laboratory
again this is all about systems based
practice collaborating with our clinical
colleagues co-creation is really key and
everybody's investing time here so make
sure that all that credit goes back that
folks time is documented and valued
thank their chair for allowing them to
participate share your annual report or
the report of projects that you've done
with leadership so everybody gets
crowded and this will build credibility
of your of your team people know that
you know what you're doing and they'll
want to send more members to help so
essential resources you really need to
have somebody help you monitor these
projects as they go through as a project
management you're gonna pull a lot of
data so you need somebody to pull the
data you need somebody to analyze the
data this may be you and maybe someone
on your team but you need to have these
people identified committee meeting
preparation and participation somebody
needs an agenda together take minutes
etc presentations and meetings you're
gonna have stent clinical stakeholders
and institutional leadership these are
represented or they're as ex officios
you're gonna want to do an impact
analysis of your projects
so you put something in place did it
work did it not work this took a
people's efforts so you're going to see
how it worked operational and it was
there any financial impact and for any
of your major initiatives you really
need to write these up both to
demonstrate internally what you've done
and please think about sharing these in
the peer review literature with your
colleagues so we don't have to continue
to reinvent the wheel
these reports end up again building
credibility for your committee as
mentioned organizational alignment we
really want to engage your a wide range
of stakeholders throughout the
organization if we're going to achieve
our our valued our desire
it comes and as you look out beyond the
laboratory you will learn and become
more and more systems oriented and you
won't always see things from the
perspective you always have seen it from
they see why things are going on and I
guarantee you it's not because people
are bad people they may not see a result
in the computer system well we can fix
that they may not know a test has been
ordered we need to show them a has been
so it doesn't get repeated so people
aren't doing it because they're bad
people so live in their shoes for a
little while and we all learn a lot
you're really going to want to have
multi specialty teams and so we're
seeking broad input diverse opinions a
open forum where everybody can speak
it's open collegial and we're gonna make
evidence-based informed decisions and
again as mentioned you look at you learn
with the laboratory looks like from
another perspective engagement
participation I need a hero
so when there are projects in in the
cardiovascular area find somebody in
that Institute or department that is
interested in this same topic and they
will be your help make them into your
clinical champion it is going to be much
easier to sell this within a group than
mandates or directives coming from
outside a group so that that person
could be aunt there at their local
meetings telling them about initiatives
rather than you coming in as an outsider
telling them what you'd like to change
this is one of the lot of my learnings
over the years has been this clinical
and pathology dyads are extremely highly
effective so really consider that your
beanie climatically financial
informatics knowledge and you really
need somebody with a skill set to really
lead a team so you have to have a leader
with some leadership skills motivations
and incentives why are we doing this
traditionally this has all been about
cutting cost right let's cut
the high cost sent out to us and that is
important we won't pretend that it's not
but it's not a good driver because we
didn't get into medicine to cut costs we
know it's important and we give its due
due respect but we really got into
medicine to make patients better to make
improvements in this space so I really
believe that the implement
implementation of best practices should
be your drivers and we will do good by
doing right you can really it will
improve and preserve engagement of
everyone on your team everyone wants to
help patients it will help those
patients you'll end up improving patient
care patient experience you'll decrease
harm
we know that iatrogenic anemia slows
wound healing increases a chance for
infection well when we work towards not
over drawing people with phlebotomy we
help to reduce that iatrogenic anemia um
decrease unnecessary tasks unnecessary
tests and a low prevalence population
have high false positive rates those
false positive rates will be followed up
with more tests maybe radiologic studies
etc and then you can also work to align
with payers there's real opportunity
here for shared savings by by payers
knowing that we are working in this
space to not to not have unnecessary
tests ordered and you can use some of
those savings to address your budgetary
gaps which is always useful so let's get
into some of the strategies and tactics
so this fishbone diagram you have the
slide so I won't read it in detail but
all of the areas in blue are going to be
some of the areas that we highlight all
of which have sub components you can see
the bones off the major bones of this
fish and of opportunities to address the
inappropriate use of laboratory tests
and why this occurs so first let's talk
about inappropriate test selection well
1 may be unnecessary
Pete orders and so these are orders that
may be ordered more frequently than
necessary we within a particular
timeframe a lipid panel and hemoglobin
a1c are good examples sometimes the
results will never change a
constitutional genetic test a thorough
test for cystic fibrosis for example we
understand that panels get expanded and
that's not what we're talking about here
we're talking about exact same tests and
why is this done sometimes the providers
unaware of their results so this is a
really a post analytic issue and again
when you're when you talk to them and
you find out that they say oh I didn't
know this was ordered well therein is a
potential solution help make that more
obvious and that's one of the things
that we've done so another issue with
inappropriate test selection is the test
provides no additional value and the
examples here is there may be no value
based on another test for example on you
know free t3 is not needed if TSH is
normal
you don't need HCV RNA if the HCV
antibody is negative those types of
things and again you know there may be
rare exceptions to any rule but these
are for the most part based on the
ability to interpret there may be no
additional value so you know the
appreciated or free PSA is uninsurable
outside of certain ranges patient
demographics so and Tommy Year location
etc a rapid strep test is really
unnecessary and provides no additional
value positive or negative if you have a
patient without pharyngitis so you get
the idea and then sometimes tell us are
basically measuring the same thing and
you may know additional value ESR and
CRP are common examples but there are
there are many others so inappropriate
test selection continued
miss ordered dust wire test miss ordered
well it may actually be a technical
problem an inadvertent test selection so
let me checked the wrong box sometimes
this is due to our the person that's
ordering and how we list these we have
an example that years ago when we
brought up HIV 2 all of a sudden there
was a flurry of HIV 2 orders although at
that time there was no no HIV 2 in the
United States well it was because there
were the HIV 2 was listed above HIV 1
and so the unit clerk was picking the
first HIV test trying to order the right
test but but not not knowing how to do
or making an error making a technical
error sometimes there's cognitive
problems right sound-alike tests are
good examples of us did you want
magnesium or manganese we've had issues
with someone ordering at cryptococcal
antibody when they really wanted a
cryptococcal antigen test sometimes on
maybe you need clarifying information
around these so those are some examples
of sound-alike tests and may cause
cognitive problems sometimes it's just a
Mis ordered test and this again is a
really a lack of understanding of how
the test functions right so
misunderstanding about specific
indications so you have an indicator you
have an example therefore
pheochromocytoma more in my space for
allergic aspergillosis we would not want
a galacto manon which is for invasive
aspergillosis the rat rather assure
logic response to a specialist and again
as mentioned sometimes these are due to
improper menu or order set configuration
and this is extremely important ask
yourself this questions when's the last
time you thoroughly went through your
ordering menu probably a while ago
when's the last time you looked at the
order sets for OBGYN or for pediatrics
probably a while ago sometimes we're not
even asked to review those and mistakes
that occur in those are long lasting
they'll be
here for many many years so that's built
in waistt in a system that will be
repeated over and over again in
appropriate test procedure and so was
either an inefficient procedure in that
case there's unnecessary work being done
maybe over processing their results in
delays and that example would be workup
a normal flora in microbiology doesn't
give any additional information it could
be an insensitive test procedure
maybe it's an obsolete or insensitive
test it has no diagnostic value or
limited diagnostic value it's still
stuck on your menu get it off
untimely result ascend out of a gram
stain's or CSF Gram stain is really not
gonna help anybody it's gonna be poor
patient care and you want to make sure
that your reflex testing is appropriate
issues with erroneous or miss ordered
results here we're talking about things
like test performance errors and we
talked about this a little bit already
so we won't belabor a specimen quality
and integrity issues so if the if it's
not a great specimen of specimen that's
compromised during transit then we're
really not getting an accurate result
with regards to what's going on
biologically probably going to be
repeated could even lead to medical harm
if something missed and again we've
already talked about cognitive problems
but again this is an opportunity to help
educate our colleagues when these things
occur and then there are a mission of
testing this is really under utilization
I think this is really coming to the
fore by newer practitioners of
laboratory stewardship where if we're
not just interested in cutting costs
which we aren't which is we're really
interested in optimizing patient care
then we care just as much about under
utilization as over utilization and
these would be things like incomplete
testing for a diagnosis you have an
example there of both tests that are
needed for the diagnose
some Wilson's disease where you want
patients with positive HCV antibodies to
get a viral load so we can have a
baseline we want to make sure these
people aren't lost to follow-up and show
up years later with cirrhosis we want
patients with chronic conditions to be
appropriately monitored and all reflex
testing like in the third bullet point
to be appropriately performed and when
they're not there really are armed there
really are no practice issues so we care
as much about under utilization as we do
over utilization so some of the
strategies are really for great big
buckets of strategies education and
feedback test order control appropriate
selection and application of laboratory
testing procedures and utilization and
test results we'll talk about these a
strategy education of feedback we know
that prospective education here how to
use these tests is very limited impact
and this goes for everything from trying
to educate about drunk driving or condom
use to to appropriate utilization of
testing so limited impact you can then
utilize decision support and this comes
in a variety of forms often we're
talking about education it's relatively
passive best practice alerts directing
people particularly and these can be
helpful sometimes folks get too many of
these they get alert fatigue and they
they end up not reading the alerts so
that's our that's a challenge there
retrospective can be very can be very
informative and can change practice this
is retrospective pull it clinician
profile and you can see in the example I
believe that is of CRP or ESR
utilization by a particular group of
physicians and you see there's one or
two really high utilizers right so those
are the folks
you wanted to target and ask why are
they so far out from the rest of their
colleagues what's really important here
is you got to compare groups with light
practices you can't compare OBGYN with
family practitioners exception and and
you can have enter institutional
benchmarking also again you want to
compare like practices strategies for
test order control again what we've
talked about with order sets we want to
get rid of obsolete tests that aren't
doing anything good we want to review
our order sets somewhat regularly we
definitely want to be involved
we are the testing experts we really
should be involved in the tests that go
on to the end of the sets again with our
clinical colleagues not independently
and they shouldn't be independent of us
working on appropriate reflex testing
algorithms it'd be great if we actually
had these built hardwired in place and
then we can actually talk about having a
tiered testing and this is an example
from the text of what to your testing
might look like at the bottom of the
pyramid you may have some tests that are
orderable by all providers the next set
up would be limited to providers on
select services maybe only certain
oncologists can order tests for tumor
markers and then you have a tier above
that some type of justification is
required and then above that you
actually have perhaps physical
intervention review and approval of the
clinical cases required I'm gonna be
very useful so I'm going to next go
through some of the strategies and
tactics that we've used and have been
demonstrated through our projects and
then some of the associated outcomes so
the first one we worked on was hard
stops for tests that biologically never
need to be ordered more than once per
day and basically what we have done
is we have built an intervention so that
if that once that test is received in
the laboratory if it's ordered with if
another one is ordered within 24 hours
there will be a block and for every one
of our interventions we give Doc's the
opportunity to override the intervention
if they think it's medically necessary
and they do that by calling client
services and getting a code that changes
every day
that allows them to override and in this
in this graph the upper red line
represents the number of initial times
the intervention fires we don't count
total number because we have people that
will try and try and try to reorder the
tests because they're not reading the
alert the bottom blue line is the number
of overrides that come through clinical
services the difference between those
two is the green are all of line and
that's the true number of stops that
month and then the purple line is the
Associated cost savings materials and
labor for not letting those tests go
through so these are individually small
low-cost tasks that you'd probably never
do an intervention on so this is our way
of casting the net widely and you can
see in the blue there's small amounts of
savings per month but that adds up over
time so Ben Franklin a small leak sinks
a great ship and so in a previous slide
in 2018 we stopped over 4,000
unnecessary tests for the full program
from January 2011 38,000 unnecessary
tests and it's 56,000 a year so not a
huge number but that's a technologists
salary and half a million as we let this
rot regional smart alerts we are asked
to do the same type of intervention for
our regional hospitals when we when we
did the
there were a number of reasons we
couldn't roll out a hard stop and so
what we did was we build the same type
of intervention but on but they could
override it at the computer screen and
so this is a this is essentially also
what the hard stop looks like and I give
one of our informatics individuals miss
Shirley stall the call out because years
ago she had the ideas that hey if
they're trying to order a test already
been ordered why don't we give them the
results of its available so not only do
we tell them they don't need the
duplicate but if the results are
available we say and here's what you
were looking for and the docs love this
so that was that's been useful in
building on building goodwill with the
physicians on the floor here in this in
this instance they can just click
through you can see on the bottom to
accept the order or not they about half
the time they I would say do the right
thinking about time a they just cooked
through but we also maintain tabs on
that and in our region in 2018 stopped
over 9,000 unnecessary tests and this
ran since October 2013 and it stopped
36,000 and again little cost savings
individually but it adds up over time so
we've done any if you want to read about
this you can you can find our paper and
american journal of clinical pathology
and we look at the effectiveness of each
of these alerts archetype versus soft
stop and the cost savings per
intervention so next is thoughts around
optimizing molecular genetic testing and
there are really three big buckets in my
mind one you can restrict testing and we
have done that I'll show you some data
on that you can use genetic guidance and
this is where laboratory based genetic
counselors are absolutely indispensable
and then you can do algorithmic testing
which we've not done is much our
colleagues at Mayo Clinic have been much
more forward-thinking with gross
developing these algorithms so those are
their websites they've done a great job
in this as and in many other areas till
our restricted use initiative basically
asked the question should anyone on
campus be able to order these expensive
molecular genetic tests when you know
they they probably don't have the like
was it training to interpret them
appropriately and we got the answer know
that we could limit these to quote
deemed users and we defined these as
individuals that use these routinely in
their practice and so the these would be
things like medical genetics and
radiology etc and so see that we and
unfortunately the dollar sign for the
2017 number that was not updated to 2018
and it's incorrect we we stopped few
tests but they end up being worth a lot
of money because all expensive and the
the number on the right is correct for
the whole program that started in
November 2011 this is running through
December 2018 601 tests stopped over
that time period for savings at 1.1
million
so definitely we're thinking about and
this gets around stopping erroneous
orders on the expensive test area ASSA t
order and one of the things that we do
is we don't look back on what happens
when these are blocked and you can see
in ambulatory setting half of the time
that's on the dark maroon on the right
they did no follow up we recommend you
know this is a restricted test you know
if you think it's clinically indicated
get a follow up with medical genetics
etc I mean patients three quarters I
didn't request to follow up so we really
think these were not needed tasks
the other portions of these pie charts
demonstrates when they did get some kind
of consult and what we love about this
is we think this is both efficient and
effective its efficient in that we're
not doing unnecessary testing we like it
as effective because we feel like we're
driving these patients that need to see
a sub specialist to the appropriate sub
specialist so we think this is a great
opportunity to to improve patient care
while we decrease unnecessary tests
employ a laboratory based genetics
counselor if you have a decent volume of
send out testing and these folks are
absolutely amazing professionals they
they review the tests that are going out
the door
these would in our place as we had
already built a restricted use
initiative they they will be reviewing
miscellaneous tests that are going out
the door and people call those by a
variety of names miscellaneous or wild
tests something like that and so these
folks are experts in genetics and they
can look into the patient chart and the
interface with the provider these folks
have great communication skills good
emotional intelligence and you can see
in 2018 they intervened on 465 tests for
a savings of two hundred thirteen
thousand and their only charge is to get
the patient the right tests it's not to
deny testing it's not to get a cheaper
test it's in their professional opinion
of what's the best test that's the
charge and the total intervention for a
program that started back in 2011
running through December 2018 almost two
million dollars to their credit and
tests that were not performed because of
their intervention I absolutely love
this slide we do a snapshot of one of
our genetics counselors
I know relatively early in this program
152 consecutive interventions what's
important to recognize is that if she
saw a test say a pediatric neurology
test and it was being ordered as a
miscellaneous by pediatric neurologist
she's less likely to intervene here's
somebody who's a deemed user ordering a
test that's in their space however if
she saw that same test ordered by a
Rheumatologist or a family practice doc
she's gonna pick up the phone and talk
to them and the docs always have the
ability to override her it's just how we
built this system just like they can
override the yeah interventions but
again she has great communication skills
great emotional intelligence and look at
what happened in the green when she
picked up the phone we followed one
hundred fifty two consecutive
interventions fifty-eight percent of the
time they decided they didn't need the
tests eighteen percent of the time the
order proceeded either because after she
talked to them it was an appropriate
test or because they demanded to have
the test but what I love about this
graph is 24 percent of the time almost a
quarter of the time they were ordering
the wrong test
she changed this you know with their
consent to a better task so if you think
about this if she had not been in place
they wrong tests an expensive wrong test
would have went out the door that test
would have been done it would have taken
in time and hopefully they would have
found out it's the wrong test care would
have been delayed so by having this
person upstream upfront intervening they
got the right test in a timely manner so
again it's efficient in that we're not
doing unnecessary testing its effective
and patient-centered in that we're
directing providers to the correct test
so really great work Jackie on this both
of these interventions were published in
journal molecular diagnostics if you
want to read more and you can see the
precipitous drop after both the
electronic restrictions and genetic test
triage
I only effect it one of the other enter
engines that we've done is expensive
test notification and here we just tell
people do you know this test is over and
we bucket it $500 and then thousand
dollar increments off and most of the
time and we also publish this in
american journal of clinical pathology
if you want to read more most of the
time the docs click through and they
still want the test about twelve to
thirteen percent of the time they don't
so it sounds like an effective
intervention but it's only firing for
expensive tests so you can see in 2018
four hundred sixty seven times the doc
said you know what i probably really
don't need this and it saved three
hundred fifty two thousand dollars so
front from the time this went live in
2013 through 2018 you know over a
thousand unnecessary tests were averted
saving the operations 1.3 million
dollars and the patient's because
remember they'll have to pay for some of
this out-of-pocket so really good for
anybody what we learned here at first
didn't want to do this test because i
said you know we're already intervening
with the restricted test with the
genetic counselor and i thought you know
this is gonna be more for the genetics
folks turned out a lot of these tests
were the newer molecular heme tests and
so on that that's some of the folks that
were being picked up by this
intervention that were not being picked
up by the other we were asked to extend
the hard stop in time and so we've done
that for a number of number of tests
seed if you can only get once every
seven days whether it's positive or
negative a hemoglobin a1c once per month
we understand the biological lifespan of
hemoglobin a1c is longer than that this
is compromised and so you will want to
think about compromise
never compromise your principles but you
don't always have to have things your
way so what will work for your
clinicians what will work for you meet
in the middle and it's better to have
things that are that are moving
you forward then not being moved at all
because of you know you know stubborn
adherence to one particular thought and
then again you can see some of the other
extent of heart stops that we have
constitutional molecular genetic tests
billet intervention for that you already
had one of these tests you don't need
another you see some of the savings
there this is a shot of all the repeat
constitutional genetic tests that we
caught in one month and so you may think
this doesn't happen it actually happens
all the time often it's because that
that can't find the result and so what
we've done is our informatics
individuals have built a intervention
that will look back and see if it's been
done before and then we tell them what's
already been done and we point them in
the right direction so they can even get
the result and the patient doesn't get
built for a second constitutional
genetic test you can help your
enterprise we had some some movement on
see difference when we when we put in a
couple of our interventions so that's
always nice to remind folks at the top
that we're doing we in the laboratory
doing great things again for the system
right three-day rule for stool cultures
and open parasite examinations we
publish these findings in journal or
clinical microbiology if you'd like to
read more about that on again not high
cost savings but this is an all about
cost cutting cost cutting comes when you
do the right thing we're implementing
evidence-based guidelines and the cost
savings whether its large or small comes
along for the ride but that's not why
we're doing duplicate blood cultures has
a really nice story about it we were
approached by colleagues in the
intensive care unit that were worried
that folks were being overdrawn for
blood cultures when we did a deep dive
and to how the blood cultures were being
drawn we actually found that people were
being that in many instances folks are
being under drawn so we took this from
an over util
to discovery underutilization and really
been an intervention to help optimal
utilization so we made sure they were
getting the right amounts drawn up front
first and then they were notified if
those blood cultures were already in
processed so they can make an informed
decision whether they wanted to do
another or not so it's a really nice
story of not just being stuck on
overutilization
really staying true to the principles of
optimal utilization education we've put
in four graphics on the Graduate Medical
Education website for the incoming
residents and fellows we've now been
invited to give talks to medical
students so trying to again push this
earlier and earlier in their education
so appropriate ordering becomes a habit
for our newer providers so here is the
financial summary of from our 2018
annual report all of these interventions
in a row you see one of them daily
orders number nine worked very good
first year and those are the numbers
down and in the cumulative totals then
the wheels came off the bus um folks
figured out a way around this and we
still need to do a deep dive to
understand that and think about if we
can reinitiate that program and this was
directed towards common orders like CBC
and chemistry's very difficult to to
address but you can see overall in 2018
stop 49,000 unnecessary tests with all
of our embedded in our interventions for
eight hundred and seventy-five thousand
savings and the whole probe i've stopped
over two hundred nine thousand
unnecessary tests for savings just shy
of six million so numbers were very
proud of again we're not letting money
drive us bought these are the numbers
that leadership likes to see at the end
of the era we're doing something to help
system the patients and the patients in
many different
from you know discomfort to having to
pay for tests they don't need etc so
finally in the document we started with
some of the other additional keys to
success that are called out is you
really have to think about change
management when you're going to put in
some of these interventions yeah you
can't over communicate notify sometimes
you're gonna be giving feedbacks don't
forget to give thanks everybody on your
team and folks that have participated in
helping you get this work done you want
to employ continuous improvement tools
again we talked a little bit about good
meeting practices and again you're gonna
want to monitor and report there's no
way we could talk about these great
successes if we had not had reports
built for every one of these
interventions so when you do a point
when you do a large-scale intervention
plan on having a report bill think about
how you want that report to look for you
even start that engine well it's being
built you need to monitor its
effectiveness and be able to report out
on the number of tesha intervened on
your the successfulness of those
interventions and if there was any kind
of financial impact of course if you
have a impact with regards to length of
stay or patient outcome or bit of
mortality absolutely report on those
things to the supplemental appendices
that the document manage and are also
very helpful if you don't have a test
utilization or a laboratory stewardship
committee it gives you an example of a
project charter gives you a sample
action plan template sample of multiple
initiative utilization cost worksheet
and a sample of a single utilization of
utilization worksheet and also gives the
at that time they've grown since then
the ABIM recommendations for laboratory
testing an initiative is don't forget to
check out choosing wisely all of
the recommendations of choosing wisely
are also great ways to think about
projects in your area and their projects
that have data behind them you can pull
the references from choosing wisely and
you have multiple groups that have come
together and agreed that these should be
in the choosing wisely recommendation so
it's not something that you dreamed up
it's actually something that's out there
talking about tests that should not be
performed so with that I will end this
webcast and wish you all good luck in
your chest utilization and laboratory or
stewardship programs and so go out there
and do great things for the patient's
through your laboratory stewardship
efforts thank you